ça a l'air facile à la maison on se dit
comment il faut en bas c'est rien tu
prends un micro tu chantes regarde Clara
la micro avec un fil bah non c'est pas
facile c'est d'abord de la passion
c'est pas facile c'est d'abord de la
passion elle est vraiment fantastique
elle a
[Applaudissements]
été très mal à l'aise après ce baiser
excusez-moi quand
elle a fait un petit peu
est-ce qu'on va faire l'amour enfin
c'est quand même un truc un peu sur
l'ambiguïté Mathieu a donné les paroles
dans un instant absolument vraiment
pardon moi je trouve que mais à quel
moment mais à quel moment un chanteur
comme ça c'est un bébé dans un coup à
une candidate pour arrêter de voir des
polémiques partout il lui fait à peine
un bisou on sait même pas si lui fait un
bisou s'il dit quelque chose dans
l'oreille et franchement ça a choqué que
trois personnes sur Twitter elle elle a
même pas l'air choqué donc voilà faut
arrêter
les gens viennent fous mais ce genre de
Vienne fou il a fait un petit bisou dans
le cou elle est majeure c'était mignon
c'était plutôt tendre j'ai même pas vu
de polémique séance pour que toi
Géraldine qui était toujours du bon côté
tout d'un coup tombe du côté du du de la
bien pensé de la merde c'est pas une
question bien-pensant c'est que
aujourd'hui lui il a 60 ans c'est un
chanteur confirmé il a pas avoir en
sorte de baiser un peu paternaliste dans
le coup genre c'est bon
non c'est pas du tout la question
absolument pas je trouve que le mot est
complètement disproportionné je trouve
que ça n'est pas un geste approprié
sauf que la principale intéressée c'est
elle dont il faut savoir que la gêné ou
dans le live après la Bible exactement
en fait la balançoire là
Valérie vous imaginez qu'après même si
ça l'a choqué elle annonce publiquement
j'ai été choqué c'est la fin de sa
carrière elle ne peut pas le dire
et moi je trouve effectivement que dans
ce geste il manque le consentement de la
personne tu veux que je te dise Gilles
tu es insupportable en fait je vais te
dire tu sais quoi tu es tout ce qu'on
aime pas ici
c'est ridicule c'était mignon c'était il
y avait un petit côté un peu le mec le
chanteur confirmé
c'est tout alors sur la joue dans le
coup c'est pas très grave il aurait dû
dire quoi est-ce que je peux t'embrasser
sur la joue mon frère mais Gilles
franchement
le prof du criminel en fait le tribunal
des réseaux sociaux maintenant on parle
à la place des gens concernés donc les
gens disent agression pervers mais
franchement c'est c'est grave de dire ça
parce que ça les vrais agressions sur
elles sont à dénoncer et là franchement
ça n'a choqué personne à part trois
abrutis sur Twitter madame alors moi je
pense que chaque femme ressent les
émotions différemment donc tu as des
femmes que ça va pas gêner comme moi
quelqu'un fait un bisou dans le cou
comme ça de manière bienveillante moi ça
m'aurait pas du tout choqué par contre
j'ai des copines que quand c'est le coup
moi j'aurais préféré la joue en fait la
joue c'est moins intime que le cou et je
me dis que alors je sais très bien on
connaît très bien Marc Lavoine ici on
l'a eu plein de fois on se sentait un
amour et que c'est absolument pas un
pervers il y a rien mais c'est vrai que
le coup ça peut être intime pour une
femme c'est de la séduction il y avait
une chanson qui était dans la séduction
et encore une fois elle est majeure tout
ça c'était pas et c'est une chanson dans
la séduction lui a fait un bisou dans la
séduction
direct sur TF1 il faut pouvoir assumer
ce baiser dans le coup d'un d'un homme
qui est chanteur qui est super connu et
qui lui fait un bisou dans le coude
apparemment pour Mathieu à toutes les
autres
tiens tu veux réagir
moi je trouve que c'est bien parce que
le coup je trouve c'est un peu intime ça
un chanteur confirmé là 60 ans la 24 ans
c'est pas sa copine il est là il fait il
fait un truc avec elle il lui faisait le
baise main ça suffisait moi demain je
vais faire un bisou dans le cou avec
Kelly pour dire bonjour amusant dans le
coeur à Valérie un bisou dans quoi
Géraldine je vais Daniel et Daniel et
Daniel aussi
[Applaudissements]
des gens qui veulent consentement
exactement Daniel elle s'en plomb
peut-être
pas ma chérie on est lis le tour